[Música]
hola soy santiago lópez gonzález
bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa primer programa de esta nueva
temporada 2021 de este espacio de france
24 en el que hacemos un resumen de las
noticias más destacadas a lo largo de la
semana relacionadas con la pandemia de
kobe 19 en nuestro continente a
continuación les presento algunos de los
temas que vamos a tratar el día de hoy
vamos a dar un vistazo al avance de los
planes de vacunación en nuestro
continente cuatro países están liderando
este proceso que se muestra dispar e
incluso lejano en algunas naciones que
aún no tienen vacunas tampoco tienen
planes aprobados para inocular a sus
ciudadanos mientras que otros países ya
van a plena marcha hablaremos también de
la situación en estados unidos con más
de 23.4 millones de casos confirmados
pero también 10 millones de personas ya
vacunadas los retos que tiene eeuu
siguen siendo muy grandes
el presidente electo joe biden ya
recibió la segunda dosis de su vacuna
contra el cob el 19 y el reino unido-
cerró la entrada a su territorio a
ciudadanos de 12 países de nuestra
región de américa latina y también
a ciudadanos procedentes de portugal y
cabo verde las autoridades británicas
temen la aparición de la variante de
kobe 19 que fue encontrada en brasil que
se sumaría a otras dos que ya
encontraron en suelo británico una local
y una procedente de sudáfrica les
contamos más en unos minutos vamos a
comenzar entonces con una cifra como les
estaba diciendo dos millones de víctimas
vieja deja ya hasta el momento el la
pandemia del cob y 19 en el mundo entero
eso nos lleva a enfocar entonces la
mirada en el proceso de vacunación que
avanza en varios países en el mundo pero
en nuestra región en américa latina la
región en donde este proceso ha sido más
irregular según lo informan algunas
organizaciones méxico chile costa rica y
argentina son los países que han puesto
en marcha ya sus respectivos planes de
vacunación mientras que otros como
brasil se están abasteciendo pero no han
dado información del inicio de la
inoculación este país estamos hablando
de brasil recibió una mala noticia desde
los laboratorios de facer en la india
que indicaron que la entrega
de 2 millones de dosis fue postergado
porque precisamente india tiene
dificultades para abastecer a otros
países de la región al igual que brasil
uruguay paraguay perú venezuela
guatemala honduras el salvador cuba la
república dominicana ya han logrado
acuerdos con las farmacéuticas colombia
también allí tienen también algunos
planes de vacunación ya diseñados
colombia ecuador y panamá como ya
decíamos tienen fechas estimadas
estimadas para el inicio de esta
inoculación en eeuu y canadá también
avanza este proceso a plena marcha
saludamos al doctor carlos eduardo pérez
él es asesor científico de france 24 es
médico infectólogo de la universidad
nacional de colombia nos acompaña desde
la capital colombiana a la ciudad de
bogotá doctor gracias por estar con
nosotros en kobe 19 la semana en américa
como siempre un gusto tenerlo con
nosotros y cuál es el balance que usted
hace del proceso de vacunación que
avanza en américa latina' como ya lo
decíamos cuatro países van liderando
otros van en el proceso y algunos
simplemente están esperando a ver qué
sucede en el resto del mundo para tomar
decisiones
santiago está pasando lo mismo que ha
pasado en la pandemia y a pesar de ser
un problema universal un problema que
nos afecta a todos es asimétrico su
comportamiento lo mismo en la vacuna que
es realmente un esfuerzo que llama a ser
globalmente para especia accesible para
todos nosotros estamos viendo como en la
misma región es asimétrica algunos
países tienen la vacuna a otros países
están comprando las vacunas a ciertos
pacientes de otros países están
implementando los programas de
vacunación es una manifestación más de
la asimetría que ha tenido el
comportamiento de la pandemia a pesar de
que todos necesitamos la vacuna pues
solamente algunos la van a tener en
estos momentos doctor de qué depende que
países como méxico costa rica chile de
argentina que los mencionábamos hayan
tenido la oportunidad de negociar antes
de tener la delantera en estos procesos
de vacunación eso depende del buenos
sistemas de salud o de una mejor
diplomacia a nivel internacional para
acercarse a las farmacéuticas de qué
depende
así que hay varios factores uno
definitivamente el acercamiento entre
gobierno e industria para poder hacer
acuerdos muy rápidos binacionales dos es
que otros países le apostaron a la
estrategia y kóvacs de la patrocinada
por la organización mundial de la salud
en donde se hacía un bloque de países
para conseguir la vacuna sin embargo eso
trajo retrasos entonces por eso es que
los acuerdos entre farmacéuticas y
gobiernos directos fueron más propicios
más propensos a hacer más rápida la
adquisición de las vacunas también la
que la regulación de cada uno de los
países le deba agilidad para que se
pudiera probar el uso de la terapia del
biológico y además de eso que tenían ya
preparado una estrategia para
implementar la vacunación apenas la
tuvieran disponible yo creo que ahí se
marcó la diferencia y algunos países se
rezagaron esperando en la estrategia
coachs y la oportunidad de tener vacuna
pero al ver que se iba a retrasar y que
solamente iba a ser hasta el segundo
semestre de 2021 empezaron a hacer los
acuerdos binacionales y hay ese retraso
de algunos países tomaron ventaja en eso
doctor eso en cuanto a la negociación
con las compañías farmacéuticas y los
gobiernos pero qué hay de los planes de
vacunación hay países con enormes
dificultades precisamente para ejercer
jurisdicción en territorios aislados los
países que tienen por ejemplo territorio
en la amazonía que hay zonas remotas de
difícil acceso eso implica un recurso
logístico o dificultades a la hora de
distribuir la vacuna para algunos países
como son estos retos
los retos son complejos son también
geográficos son de accesibilidad pero
también son retos de voluntariedad de
las personas para poderse vacunar es una
gran dificultad que tenemos porque hay
más la desinformación que información
acerca de esta realidad entonces como se
ha planteado se necesitan centros de
acopios centrales que se vayan estos
centros de acopio haciendo en regiones
para que sean cada vez en regiones más
pequeñas que esas regiones de acopio
cumplan con todas las cadenas de frío
que requieren algunas de las vacunas y
probablemente en las zonas más
periféricas no se utilicen vacunas que
requieran cadena de frío sino que sean
de una sola dosis y que no requieran
digamos todos estos protocolos de
seguridad entonces el reto va a ser que
vacunas en qué grupo de población las
que tengan alta cadena de frío y centros
de acopio y en las regiones periféricas
vacunas de una sola dosis simpad en
haití en eso por eso hay que tener
grande no solamente una vacuna sino
varias vacunas para poder planear la
estrategia y hacerla de acuerdo a la
geografía de cada para decir la
capacidad de cada país
pero claro que la gente cree en la
vacuna y cuando está disponible puede
acceder a ella doctor y también es clave
que nos sigamos cuidando pese a que el
proceso de vacunación está avanzando más
en unos países que en otros como ya lo
veíamos es clave que la gente siga
teniendo todas las precauciones cuál es
el llamado que usted hace
la vacunación es el principio del fin de
la pandemia pero el fin de la pandemia
es que no haya más infectados entonces
una vez se inicie la vacunación se debe
continuar con la protección porque al
colocarse una vacuna no quiere decir que
inmediatamente nosotros no nos vaya a
dar corona dios va a ser en la primera
semana de la segunda dosis pero
alrededor de nosotros va a haber más
gente que se puede contagiar si la demás
gente no se vacuna va a haber más
infectados y si hay más infectados puede
haber cambios mutaciones y linajes
distintos y la vacuna que tenemos
pudiera ser no efectiva por eso en este
año es vacunación manteniendo las
medidas de disminución de la aceleración
de casos para que sea el fin de la
pandemia si hacemos solamente una cosa
vacunación y no controlamos la
propagación no va a funcionar doctor
muchas gracias por esta explicación y
por hacer este llamado a los
televidentes de kobe 19 la semana en
américa aquí en france 24 como siempre
un gusto vamos a seguir con otros temas
del programa el coronavirus como ya lo
decíamos sigue expandiéndose rápidamente
en el continente americano este
continente
la cifra récord de 2.5 millones de casos
nuevos de kobe 19 en una semana esto nos
lleva a un total de más de 40 millones
de casos en toda américa y las víctimas
ya se cuentan por cerca de 900 mil el
llamado de la opc a los gobiernos es a
seguir luchando contra el virus y a los
ciudadanos a seguir cuidándose
américa es la región más afectada por el
coronavirus en el mundo con un total de
40 millones de casos y casi un millón de
muertes atraviesa el peor momento de la
pandemia según la organización
panamericana de la salud en que las
ubica no sólo en la última semana 2,5
millones de personas se contagiaron por
el comité 19 en nuestra región
la cifra de casos semanal más elevada
desde que el virus ha alcanzado en
nuestras costas por primera vez
esta es una vacuna que necesita
refrigeración no extrema pero necesita
refrigeración que es distribuida luego a
todas las provincias para que las
provincias a su vez determinen cómo van
a ir y inoculando a la población
objetivo como decía la población
objetivo en este momento tiene que ver
con trabajadores vinculados con el
sistema de salud la prioridad luego será
personas mayores de 65 años personas con
enfermedades asociadas que pueden tener
mayor riesgo pero este es el primer
primer paso como decía también por ahora
es un número limitado se espera según
información del gobierno
que alrededor de 20 millones de dosis
sean las que se reciban de esta vacuna
tal vez un poco más hacia marzo pero
estos contratos que hay firmados con los
proveedores de las vacunas son
confidenciales los gobiernos por lo
menos el argentino no lo está mostrando
entonces toda la información que
nosotros tenemos es de palabra hay que
confiar en que la información es la que
está en los contratos porque los
contratos no son públicos y no los están
dando a conocer
natalia ustedes están allí en plena
época de verano hace muchísimo calor en
argentina y las personas están en
vacaciones pero la emergencia persiste
allí en este país por supuesto qué
medidas mantiene el gobierno argentino
para seguir haciendo frente a la
pandemia
si esto es interesante porque hacia
fines de diciembre había habido como una
suerte de caída en la velocidad de
contagios y otra vez desde fines de
diciembre hasta ahora se ha acelerado de
hecho hasta esta fecha aproximadamente
mediados de enero crecieron en un 44% de
los casos con respecto a lo que había a
fines del año 2020 o sea que la
velocidad de contagio se aceleró si eran
unos 5.200 contagios diarios al 12 de
diciembre al 12 de enero hubo más de
13.700 es como que se volvió las cifras
anteriores y entonces hubo una reacción
del gobierno para tratar de frenar eso
con restricciones que están
implementando cada provincia según sus
propios criterios
natalio muchas gracias por este reporte
desde neuquén en el sur de argentina
vamos a seguir conociendo más detalles
de lo que sucede en otras regiones de
américa latina' el gobierno de la ciudad
de bogotá la capital colombiana impuso
nuevamente cuarentena sectorizadas a lo
largo de esta semana comenzando por los
barrios que tienen mayor incidencia de
casos de coronavirus la medida fue
impuesta debido por su
al alto porcentaje de la ocupación de
las salas de cuidado intensivo que ya es
superior al 85% este fin de semana la
capital colombiana estará en
confinamiento riguroso general
regreso al encierro bogotá la capital de
colombia volverá a entrar en cuarentena
estricta este fin de semana así lo
anunció la alcaldesa de la ciudad
claudia lópez desde las 8 de la noche
del viernes
hasta
a las 4 de la mañana del lunes
volveremos a estar nuevamente todos en
casa el domingo a una cuarentena general
nuevamente en la ciudad de bogotá el
gobierno local también anunció nuevas
restricciones para varios barrios
bogotanos del sur que se suman a las que
ya imperan en las zonas del norte eso
significa que todo el mes de enero
transcurrirá entre cuarentenas
escalonadas en diferentes localidades de
la ciudad
si opino que los puestos de control
están bien por localidades nos afecta
mucha gente pero tenemos que parar el
contagio son medidas que buscan frenar
la segunda ola de contagios de kobe 19
agravada por las celebraciones y los
viajes de las vacaciones navideñas pero
que evitan el encierro total que se
vivió en marzo abril y mayo en el país
bogotá no es la única ciudad que vuelve
a registrar altas cifras de muertes y
contagios de kobe 19 los hospitales en
cali están desbordados y medellín tiene
más del 85% de las luces ocupadas ante
este panorama al presidente iván duque
recibió críticas por el lento despliegue
del programa de vacunación que está
previsto que empiece en febrero aunque
gran parte de la infraestructura todavía
no está lista
colombia ha asegurado 49 millones de
dosis de vacunas suficientes para
proteger unos 29 millones de personas
poco más de la mitad de la población
total del país
y nuevamente hay dificultades en manaos
en el estado de amazonas en el norte de
brasil los hospitales de esta región
están completamente saturados en algunos
de ellos incluso falta el suministro de
oxígeno y los pacientes más graves son
derivados a otras ciudades o incluso
algunos estados esta es la situación
sin oxígeno así se están quedando
decenas de pacientes en los hospitales
de manaus en la amazonía de brasil el
sistema de salud local está colapsando
otra vez como ocurrió en abril los
centros de salud envían a hospitalizados
a otras ciudades el ejército llevó
suplementos luego de que el estado de
amazonas le hiciera un llamado urgente y
las autoridades decretaron un toque de
queda de 11 horas en manaos entre las 19
y las 6 de la mañana pero para muchos
las medidas llegan tarde como para mail
y quien perdió a su abuela por la
escasez de implementos y por ello salió
a protestar
mi abuela murió hoy por falta de oxígeno
y sus partes había 21 pacientes en la
uci divididos en grupos iguales y mi
abuela de 84 años no pudo sobrevivir
necesitaba 15 litros de oxígeno por
minuto pero no había suficiente
investigadores creen que el nuevo
repunte del cobi 19 en amazonas se debe
en parte a la variante del virus que se
descubrió en el estado brasileño y que
las autoridades confirmaron esta semana
pero para el ministerio de salud la
crisis sanitaria es porque los
hospitales no trataron los pacientes a
tiempo
manaus notebook
manaos no contaba con un plan de acción
efectivo para el tratamiento temprano
con diagnóstico clínico atención básica
y eso apartado mucho en la gravedad del
virus y en su impacto mundo a gravedad y
la web esta semana japón confirmó cuatro
casos de la variante de brasil y reino
unido prohibió los vuelos provenientes
del país y de sudamérica por la misma
razón mientras que algunos brasileños en
otras ciudades temen que la mutación se
propague con la revisión de pacientes
provenientes de manaos
y mientras tanto en perú la federación
médica de ese país que es la agremiación
que reúne a los médicos del sistema
público de salud dio inicio a una huelga
nacional indefinida para exigir mejores
condiciones mientras combaten el kobe 19
en ese país vamos a conocer más detalles
con francisco zacarías corresponsal de
france 24 en la ciudad de lima la
capital peruana hola francisco se
mantiene esta huelga del personal
sanitario que avances hay
santiago buenas noches como se lo dice
la huelga se mantiene y los trabajadores
sanitarios han dicho que continuará
indefinida mientras el gobierno del
presidente francisco sagasti no
solucione sus demandas ellos están
reclamando un mayor presupuesto a la
salud pública mejores condiciones
salariales y laborales así como equipos
de protección personal para protegerse
de contagios del coi 19 france24 ha
estado cubriendo esta crisis esta semana
y precisamente godofredo talavera
presidente de la federación médica
peruana me dijo que más de 800
trabajadores sanitarios han muerto en
sus labores atendiendo a la pandemia del
coi 19 en condiciones que el gremio
médico califica como precarias francisco
cómo afecta esto a los pacientes que
están recibiendo atención porque ya
fueron diagnosticados con kobe 19
precisamente el gremio médico ha
comunicado que está dispuesto en todos
los hospitales del país no se descuide
la atención en los servicios de urgencia
y también se brinde atención prioritario
a los pacientes de kobe 19 pero desde
los nosocomios de esta nación se señala
que la emergencia radica en la falta de
las camas en las unidades de cuidados
intensivos que han comenzado a escasear
y precisamente fiore al amor y neil y
quien es la presidenta del sistema de
seguridad nacional ha dicho que en todo
el sistema nacional las unidades de
cuidados intensivos están al tope al 90
por ciento en sus servicios y en
aquellas regiones donde la segunda ola
de la pandemia ha empezado a repuntar el
lleno está casi al 100%
francisco eso en cuanto a la situación
de los médicos y los pacientes pero que
dice entonces el gobierno del presidente
de sagasta
precisamente la ministra de salud pilar
mazzetti ha reconocido que el reclamo de
los trabajadores sanitarios es razonable
y justo y ella se ha comprometido a que
el gobierno del presidente salga así
para buscar soluciones para que las
condiciones laborales de los médicos
continuando en normalidad y respecto a
la emergencia en los hospitales ha dicho
que el gobierno peruano va a disponer de
la logística necesaria para poder suplir
la falta de camas en los hospitales del
perú francisco y cómo avanza el proceso
de adquisición de las vacunas allí en
perú y que otras medidas ha impuesto el
gobierno del presidente sagasti para
seguir haciendo frente a la pandemia en
este país recordemos que perú ha sido
uno de los más afectados sobre todo
durante el 2000 el 2020 al inicio de la
pandemia
justamente el presidente francisco
sagasti dispuso él
adelanto del toque de queda en el perú
ha ordenado que se disminuya el aforo en
los centros comerciales se ha prohibido
el ingreso a las playas a los ciudadanos
y también se ha declarado la inmovilidad
los días domingos entre las medidas más
importantes y perfecto
si francisco muchas gracias por este
reporte desde la ciudad de lima la
capital peruana francisco sacarían
nuestro corresponsal dando los detalles
de la situación en ese país suramericano
hablemos ahora de eeuu que con más de
23.3 millones de casos confirmados de
kobe 19 también está haciendo frente a
la pandemia con la vacunación de sus
ciudadanos 10 millones de personas ya
recibieron la primera dosis la gran
cantidad de gente como vemos en esta
cifra por vacunar deja en evidencia el
enorme desafío logístico que tiene este
país para poder mitigar
un poco esta crisis sanitaria porque el
avance del coronavirus no da signos de
desaceleración en ese país hace un mes
comenzaron las vacunaciones en eeuu
hasta ahora solamente el 3% de la
población ha sido inoculado recordemos
que los expertos indican que la
inmunidad del rebaño se alcanza cuando
ha sido vacunado cerca del 75% de la
población de un territorio
y vamos a seguir en eeuu allí el
presidente electo joe biden que tomará
posesión de su cargo el 20 de enero
recibió ya la segunda dosis de la vacuna
elaborada por facer vayant erc contra el
cob y 19 bailén fue inoculado en el
estado de delaware que es su lugar de
residencia privada el presidente electo
que por su edad tiene 78 años hace parte
del grupo de personas de riesgo aseguró
que no hay nada que temer refiriéndose a
este procedimiento de inoculación y a la
seguridad de las vacunas baiden recalcó
que la vacunación y la lucha contra la
pandemia será una prioridad de su
gobierno dijo que habrá 100 millones de
vacunados en sus 100 primeros días de
gobierno
seguimos en eeuu las autoridades del
estado de california estado donde se
contabilizan más de 2.8 millones de
casos anunciaron que el parque de
atracciones de disneylandia se
convertirá en un centro de vacunación
contra el corby 19 el parque que es uno
de los principales atractivos turísticos
de este estado permanece cerrado desde
marzo del 2020 por causa de la pandemia
por supuesto el gobierno del condado de
orange indicaron que el por qué será que
este será el parque el primer punto de
vacunación en california para así evitar
exponer a los ciudadanos a que tengan
que ir a hospitales oa centros de
asistencia que están completamente
saturados por los pacientes que han sido
diagnosticados con kobe 19
y estos procesos de vacunación no se
escapan de ser politizados el gobierno
de méxico aseguró que podría apelar el
nuevo tratado de libre comercio que fue
suscrito con eeuu y canadá a fin de que
los migrantes trabajadores en esos
países tengan acceso también a la vacuna
contra el cob y 19 sin importar el tipo
de estatus migratorio que tengan así lo
destacó el canciller mexicano marcelo
ebrard
es un derecho a laborar la va a comer no
pero si es un derecho establecido que el
trabajador no debe estar expuesto al
contagio
entonces en aplicándose la vacuna es una
responsabilidad de cada uno de los dos
países garantizar que todos los
trabajadores independientemente de su
condición migratoria reciban la vacuna
consideramos que cualquier exclusión de
trabajadores mexicanas o mexicanos es
una violación del tratado de libre
comercio con la misma energía fuerza
la insistencia también le pediremos su
solidaridad del movimiento obrero allá
pero en particular las nuevas
autoridades en eeuu para que se cumplan
al cien por ciento con este proyecto y
el pasado 19 de diciembre el gobierno de
la ciudad de méxico decretó el cierre
total de restaurantes y de negocios
considerados no esenciales pero esta
semana en una decisión completamente
desesperada para poder sobrevivir 500
establecimientos abrieron sus puertas
pese a que por supuesto esto va en
contra de las reglas que ha dictado el
gobierno local
abrimos o morimos bajo este lema y
cacerola en mano el gremio de
restauración de ciudad de mexico
protesta en contra de las medidas que
les impiden abrir sus establecimientos
ante el aumento de hospitalizaciones en
la capital de méxico el gobierno local
decretó semáforo rojo el pasado 19 de
diciembre lo que implica el cierre total
de la restauración salvo servicios a
domicilio pero más de 500 restaurantes
desafiaron la medida y decidieron abrir
sus puertas alegando que se trata de una
medida desesperada lo que pasa que no no
pudimos lograr un acuerdo a pesar de que
les dijimos que íbamos a ir no nos
creyeron que estábamos dispuestos a
abrir
estamos tan desesperados que estamos
abriendo porque si no la opción que nos
dieron es la muerte el pasado 7 de enero
más de 500 empresas emitieron un
comunicado solicitando diálogo a las
autoridades pero por el momento no han
recibido respuesta y alegan que acatarán
las medidas del gobierno siempre que se
les dé una solución para poder abrir
y cada día perdemos más puestos
no sé porque enfrentamos o se nos van a
dar porque también cerrado y las
autoridades nos están entendiendo y nos
están ayudando de verdad estamos
muriéndonos la solución para los
restaurantes podría llegar con el avance
de la vacunación masiva que este martes
pasar a una fase de expansión que
extenderá la vacunación para el personal
médico de los 32 estados del país el
gobierno anunció también que este martes
recibirá el primer cargamento masivo de
la vacuna facer y la posibilidad de
adquirir 24 millones de dosis de la
vacuna rusa y el temor llevó a las
autoridades del reino unido a restringir
el ingreso de viajeros procedentes de 14
países entre ellos 12 países
latinoamericanos así lo indicó el
ministro de transporte del reino unido-
escuchemos
hay una prohibición de viajar desde
brasil y en realidad creo que otros 14
países sudamericanos y también portugal
porque existe una nueva variante hemos
visto estas variantes antes hay miles de
ellas por supuesto pero algunas de ellas
se transmiten más fácilmente son
obviamente de mayor preocupación y
crisis esta medida ya entró en vigor
pero esto no implica la suspensión de
los vuelos entre estos 12 países
latinoamericanos y el reino unido louis
ha pulido desde londres la capital
británica nos da más detalles de esta
medida y también de como el reino unido
ha comenzado a blindar sus fronteras
ante el surgimiento de algunas variantes
de kobe 19 una surgió precisamente en su
territorio la otra en sudáfrica
el gobierno británico adoptó esta
determinación para evitar que la nueva
variante de coronavirus en contra brasil
llegue al reino unido- y es que aunque
inglaterra está en su tercer
confinamiento desde marzo y los otros
países de la unión tienen medidas
similares lo cierto es que la situación
sigue siendo muy delicada de nuevos
contagios y de muertes en el caso de las
restricciones para américa latina éstas
además de brasil son para colombia para
argentina para chile para uruguay para
perú para paraguay para venezuela y
otros países latinos en el caso de
portugal y de cabo verde se adopta esta
medida también por sus lazos muy
cercanos con brasil sólo podrán ingresar
al reino unido- quienes sean ciudadanos
británicos irlandeses obtengan su
residencia legal en este país
en ese caso deberán estar aislados por
diez días y en otra medida que ha sido
altamente criticada por la tardanza con
la que llega y es que este lunes 18 de
enero
cualquier persona que llegue al reino
unido desde cualquier destino del mundo
debe presentar una prueba negativa del
coronavirus estas personas también
tendrán que estar aisladas por 10 días y
presentar una nueva prueba negativa para
poder salir de sus confinamientos a los
5 días en nuestra sección en redes
veamos otras noticias destacadas de la
semana aquí en kobe 19 de la semana en
américa destacamos esta entrevista hecha
por france 24 a anthony fauci consejero
médico en jefe del presidente electo de
eeuu joe biden
fauci indicó que la vacuna contra el
kobe 19 o las vacunas dan esperanza a la
humanidad y permitiría regresar a la
normalidad en el otoño boreal de este
año el 2021 la entrevista completa la
pueden ver en france 24 punto com y
también en nuestras redes sociales en
nuestro canal de youtube
y costa rica inició la aplicación de la
segunda dosis de la vacuna contra el cob
y 19 es decir que quienes recibieron la
primera dosis el 24 de diciembre del
2020 fecha que inició esta inmunización
nacional ya tienen el esquema completo
costa rica como lo decíamos es uno de
los cuatro países de la región que
lidera la vacunación contra el kobe 19
en américa latina'
es todo por el momento en este resumen
semanal de france 24 los espero la
próxima semana y recuerden la lucha
contra el hobbit 19 sigue por favor
cuídense sigan con nosotros
[Música]